oh boy oh this is a snapchat bit work
that has been real cray-cray
you look awful yeah just saying look at
you well I can't help us look like can
you try
I did too you can say it I think I look
pretty
he was disgusting put an X over her face
yeah X me out doesn't snapchat not to go
if you're like I don't look so good I'm
just gonna reception there you go change
it back I think we're gonna get a little
bit of a storm yeah I think I need
that's your face we're gonna go walk on
the dunes Wow
let's get up there before trite as the
dole that's been a really great vine
pretty proud of it could quite possibly
be some of my best work cuz breeze free
breeze falling cuz breeze hey the real
question is are you filming when you
were trying to come I was trying to do a
handstand
no get that out of my oh excuse me
excuse me
well I'm gonna have to steal a clip of
that cuz uh I was really good in ER
veloute specialist is here valuation
neck was it Bri here hook this is for
you Buzzard know the booty specialist
oh yeah shake that shake that up without
a summer breeze woody video no wait what
oh oh oh my god I said she oh my gosh
everybody Jeff it Jeff it right now you
heard it here first
zip it zip it make a dip out of it no
where's the man excuse me my sister
wants to get in that box could she get
that box just ask just ask just ask hey
[Music]
the power kite snap you're missing some
good stuff over there I'm just saying it
I just seem really really hard to figure
out what it is
my lip rings this logged up close I'll
see you guys later go to the tea girl
Thank You battery
[Music]
guys wake up we're gonna go get
breakfast and we'll I heard in my
slumber